oh
shoot
i didn't grab anything to drink
well luckily
i have water on hand that i do keep near
the desk so it's all right i'm perfectly
fine and i will be sure to uh stay
hydrated
anyways hope folks are doing well
somebody um
you know what carowind do me a favor
um before the next stream kick me in the
ass and make me
um
put together uh
like a
not necessarily a countdown but like a
like a waiting room thing or something
so i don't just start out of nowhere
and like i just need to i just need to
create a new scene in obs is all i need
to do and
yeah kick me in the ass and make me do
it please
uh
hugs from brazil thank you marcos thank
you everyone who is
uh currently here
so um
i guess couple of things up front
um as per usual uh i will
do my best to keep up with the chat
uh super chats are what guarantees i
will read your comment and or question
otherwise i will just try and keep up as
best i can super chat also gets you a
heart from me
uh and yeah we i have
little doubt that doctor who's probably
gonna be the prominent topic so if you
haven't seen the first episode of doctor
who flux
um
this is probably going to be a spoiler
zone
so
that's your warning people who show up
later
should have got here sooner when i
warned you so there we go
the opening just made me sad and we
didn't get a season with 13 and yaz yaz
needed so much more time
i
like here's the thing i don't
uh
oh good i'm i thank you carolyn i don't
um
he's like on paper i agree with you like
i was not happy when i found out dan was
going to be a character because
i really wanted there to be built a core
relationship for jody whitaker's doctor
because it there really hasn't been
honestly the fam
in the first two series that she's had
have related more with each other than
they have with the doctor and that's
been a problem for me and the idea of it
just being her and yaz i thought had a
lot of possibilities that having been
said i i don't want to become the person
who says well in chimneys hands it
wasn't gonna work but like the simple
truth is i don't trust the guy
as a writer on this show um
and again this is not like a oh he's
going to push in the jenny's gonna he's
just not very good
most of the stuff that i've liked was
written by people who aren't him so
knowing that this is a series he's
writing entirely on his own or almost
entirely on his own
um and he's definitely involved in all
six episodes then you know i um
part of me thinks you know what
maybe it's it's just as well
i'm doing a live stream in a reasonable
time for folks in the uk this is what i
always do it
phil
uh
have you played the ps3 ghostbusters
game it was written by dan and harold
and was their idea for ghostbusters
three i have not
um i don't know if i will because it is
unfortunately fully 3d rendered third
person
which tends to make me motion sick
so i i think the odds of me ever playing
that are slim i can usually only get
about an hour at a go with games like
that sometimes not even that before i
have to stop because i get motion sick
and need to lie down
ms wicked wolf i it's not that i don't
believe you that there's a diana musical
is that i don't care
i don't
so i don't know why you keep bringing it
up
i talked to dan a lot more than i
expected to yeah ditto carolyn he he
brought um
he brought a real like ability to the
part
i'm not sure how much was there on paper
but um yeah he's he's he's bringing
something to it i'm liking it so far
as far as as far as he goes how was your
halloween i saw a live screening of the
1925 silent film phantom of the opera
live with music very cool
uh my halloween was standard um i
uh my kiddo went out she had a mask as
part of her costume um and i followed
with an umbrella cause it was raining
the
entire time
yes i know daylight savings ends this
sunday which means i i get to stop from
having to remember to say that this
starts at 7 p.m
east
eastern daylight time i can just go back
to eastern standard time
um oh
cassielle thank you very much for the
super chat
i also bet the that chris
will be announced as the 14th doctor he
just seemed to like i can't even
remember what the heck was it
all right there was something that i saw
that like he was going to be involved
and i'm like is he just like the only
person anybody has the phone number for
in hollywood anymore what the heck was
it
oh he's got a voice garfield now
like
that that one is
honestly
possibly even more puzzling than the
mario thing like the mario thing doesn't
make sense until you realize
illumination is making it then it makes
total frickin sense
garfield
what
[Music]
i don't
i don't even i don't even know what to
do with that
yeah
why is he popping up everywhere
like i don't
i'm not a huge fan of chris pratt i know
some people have very big issues with
him but like i don't
get why he's like
a big deal especially in like
suddenly in voicing and animated stuff
like he was good in the lego movies but
okay
between the museum and the food bank
scenes dan just seems like a good person
and i like playing good people yeah
nothing wrong with that
uh
garfield is so weird because bill murray
is already perfect no lorenzo music is
perfect
bill murray was
fine now granted bill murray still alive
and lorenzo music is dead but don't call
bill murray the perfect garfield when
the perfect garfield sadly is no longer
with us but is very definitively not
bill murray
okay
okay
hey
uh the one good thing about us not
getting series of just the doctrine he
has is that we have a place for the
future big finish audios to fit in
that's true
if uh
if if they do agree to get involved with
big finish at some point down the line
that is probably where a big finish is
going to nestle in is going to be
between series 12 and 13 when the doctor
is just with the ass
like that that's pr that's right in
their wheelhouse they would be all over
that
the vacuum of contents
there is a heart for you thank you for
the super chat it's been oh
ben
this is my review channel i started my
video uh counting the nodding in your
book will be on here so prepared for
judgment
i did actually see the first video you
put up and you sent me a link to it and
uh it was short enough that i actually
had the time for it this is not an
invitation for people to send me links
to your stuff like i i don't i don't
usually have time um but like that
i was it was it was nice it was a solid
start it was funny i liked it
um
[Music]
let's see here
uh i know this is petty but do you like
my reaction to your costume
um
i feel like i'm missing something
context-wise
um
oh like like a comment on the when when
i put up a picture
because i don't remember most of the
comments and i definitely don't remember
who made them so
i
my brain is not built to hold that
knowledge
it just isn't
sorry
uh
it's 40 degrees
where i live uh what have we got here
these days
it is currently it's been getting colder
i've had to bust out the the heavier
blanket so that i can still sleep naked
and not be too cold um it's currently 39
it's been
it's been high 30s low 40s lately
well that and that's uh that's
fahrenheit so
i don't know what that is uh celsius for
folks and i ain't gonna convert it
uh
do i hate daylight savings time yes it's
stupid and we shouldn't do it anymore
it's very very dumb uh
have you seen the new doctor who poop
vids um i i've seen that some are up i'm
not actually that into youtube poop as a
as like a video genre it's not i mean
like every now and then i'll get some
enjoyment out of one but this is
not really my thing
uh guardians of the galaxy game is
actually pretty great i've heard
surprisingly decent things about that
one still don't intend to play it but
i've heard decent things um
chris pratt is basically becoming the
replacement voice actor to seth rogen
um
i guess i could kinda see that
is autumn my season it both um
is and it isn't like i love autumn
um i i love the sort of
50s temperature range i especially where
i live the
leaves changing is gorgeous um but it
also tends to be a season along with
spring that is more likely to set off
migraines for me because of the
temperature variances being as severe as
they are from day to day or even within
the same day that has a tendency to
trigger my migraines so
i have a
i have a love hate relationship with
autumn what do i think of weighted
blanket um
i've actually never had one i mean when
i say that like i busted out a heavy
blanket i mean it's it's not a weighted
blanket but it's a big thick
thick blanket so i don't think i've
actually tried
you know the things that are currently
marketed as weighted blankets
even in summer i can't sleep naked i
need a t-shirt or i keep waking up
i don't need a t-shirt
i have stuffed animals i'm fine
um
was she joking who knows
i think the only perfect uh doctor today
is tommy was so alien like acting check
mysterious age check weird but kind of
attractive appearance check
hard disagree on that one wardrobe only
an alien would like check um i mean cute
pitch but like
no
um
strum dynasty gaming thank you very much
for the super chat
no comment or question but thank you all
the same much appreciated have you ever
had chocolate for breakfast um i've had
chocolate with breakfast
um but no not really
beer you want to see
rose coming back for the 2022 specials
or do you think rose is done i don't
i don't
know what there is left to do with her
like her story is finished and this is
something that in general
long-form storytelling because this is a
big problem with comics especially but
long-form storytelling like they need to
be willing to let a story be
done
they need
they need to let it just
we hit an end point fine leave it alone
then go do something else and i kind of
feel like rose fits in that category
um
do i think joe having a type 40 tardis
means the doctor has stolen the tardis
thousands of times
until we get an explanation i think joe
having a type 40 tardis means that chris
chibnall wasn't paying attention to what
the heck he was doing
until proven otherwise that's my
operating assumption and i hope to be
proven otherwise to be clear
but
until i get an answer for
the for how much time has passed with so
many dangling questions
[Music]
and no clear answers to them i'm
more inclined to chalk it up to bad
writing at this point
uh
what's your favorite muppet show episode
i don't know
i don't remember individual episodes of
the muppet show
what
ah
i think i like the halloween apocalypse
more than you did but i agree it's a bit
overstuffed i wonder how much is a side
effect of a curtailed season from eight
to six
ah
possibly
some of it but like
here's the thing
it's not that it's overstuffed it's that
it's badly paced
it's perfectly fine across six episodes
to have this many storylines but to
introduce
so many of these things right at the
right at the beginning when you don't
have time to establish why we are meant
to care about nearly any of them
and it it's just assumed that we're
going to care you know what the whole
thing reminds me of to be honest
the the way that because this is
something that's been actually been
ticking me off in the comments section
on
on my review are people who seem to be
taking a position that basically amounts
to
because it's serialized i shouldn't be
complaining that there's a bunch of
stuff that i don't know why it's there
and i reject that
because good serialization should have
me intrigued to find out not going wait
why is this is all just too much so it's
not that it's over it well it is that
it's overstuffed but it's more that it's
badly paced that it has crammed all this
and not given me a central pillar to
hold on to to make a comparison that
first season of stranger things has a
lot going on but you know why it works
right from the beginning is because we
have a core central pillar of missing
child will byers is missing what
happened to him and everything else
circles around this core thing that we
understand there is no central pillar
to the halloween apocalypse it's just a
mess of elements
and that's why even if all these things
get explained
it's still a bad opening
anyways
um sorry to bring this up but what do
you think of this let's go brandon
nonsense i
have no idea what the hell you are
talking about black cover
so uh i have no opinion because i
i like you said words
and i do not know what they mean
all right we got some more super chats
brian l thank you very much for that if
you're the doctor you if i were the
doctor you'd be my companion
you'd have to convince me to travel with
you first don't presume
oh new type jb lee thank you very much i
wonder if the reason why you're so
lukewarm in the fifth doctor's era is
that
he has a weak bloated supporting cast
that actually is part of it i have
nailed down that that's at least part of
it that he doesn't have a core
relationship i've realized that that is
part of the problem that i have with
both him
and jody whitaker because
like you can have various companies come
and going but every other doctor
you can point to one at least one some
of them had multiple
that is the definitive relationship that
helps you understand who this doctor is
because of the way the relationship with
a certain companion works
first doctor it was susan second doctor
was jamie third doctor was joe fourth
doctor was initially sarah jane and then
they did it again with romana sixth
doctor he didn't really have one that
was part of his problem too but there
were a lot of other problems going on
there too seventh doctor it's ace eighth
doctor you've gotta get into big finish
but there's a number of options there
ninth doctor rose tenth doctor it's
debatable i say it's donna but you could
still say rose because the nature of
that relationship was still different
enough that from the one that nine had
with her that that still certainly works
11 it was amy 12 as much as i don't love
it it was clara
13 and 5 it's
i guess with 13 it's yaz by default
because she'll be the one who's been
there the whole time but
there isn't much to them as a
as an interaction as a relationship and
yeah that's a big problem for me and it
is a problem with five for me as well
who's my favorite muppet then i as i've
gotten older i've grown an appreciation
of sam the eagle i do still like animal
though
my theory is that the fugitive doctor is
the one who worked for the division and
fought against swarm in the future maybe
i mean that's the
that is the um
i would say safest bet
um which given chibnell probably means
that's what's going on um unless he
pulls something completely out of his
rear end which i would say is
equally possible
uh
uh what are your opinions on dan i think
he works a lot better with yaz than she
did with graham and ryan even though i
still like them um
it's too early to call
it does kind of feel a little bit like
they've created at least a framework for
a relationship between him and yaz a lot
more than they had with graham and ryan
where it was like just oh she knows ryan
from when they were younger okay
so
whereas here like just kind of
establishing like the local rivalry
between sheffield and liverpool honestly
does more for their dynamic than
much of what it went on between
ryan and graham and her so
let's go brandon is the republican
saying f biden started at a football
game oh okay then my opinion is it's
stupid
i'm not even insulted or offended i'm
just like that's dumb okay
uh and then there was leela for the
fourth doctor interesting choice uh i'd
argue teagan uh in the show nissan big
finish teagan uh was in all but two of
his stories
yeah but i don't really feel like there
was a a core it's not just about being
there the longest it's about the
relationship and understanding the
doctor through the dynamic he has
with the companion what's his dynamic
with tegan
i mean if you know tell me because i
don't
sorry
i would say evil in his sixth defining
companion yes uh drought detective i
would agree with that
i was surprised the uh i was surprised
with olive garden dinner today
congratulations hope you liked it
um
have you ever found the grinch relatable
not really
you're not supposed to
you know
my least favorite muppet none there's no
such thing as a bad muppet
gotta say i like clara she'll never be
as good as amy and rory but i liked
clara and that's fine
i don't but that's fine
personally i'd say 13's definitive
campaign so far as graham i really liked
and understood their relationship
i did understand what their dynamic was
better than the others but it was still
fairly
shallow
but yeah
oh uh declan
thank you very much oh and high voltage
i didn't i didn't uh i didn't give you a
heart so there's one for you high
voltage and here's one for declan
um
do you hope to get a new composer soon
maybe when rtd comes back remember uh to
or struggle to remember really any of
segun
uh echanola's music apart from the
cybermen
um
it doesn't matter to me that much
like a lot
a lot of people have gotten hung up on
that and like the music is less
memorable but it's not bad
they've gone for a more low-key ambient
thing overall and it fits the different
visual aesthetic that the show currently
has and the
cinematography approach that it's been
doing with the new series so i think
it's been a decent pairing to visual
approach of visual approach and
um music composer
do i miss some of the um more bombastic
stuff from murray gold yeah
am i
ever gonna buy the soundtrack to um
do any of the series that we've had uh
with this new composer
probably not but i don't i don't it's
not something i'm hung up on
it it's just not
i think part of it is that by the time
murray gold wrapped up i was i did kind
of agree like no it's probably time for
him to move on anyways
so
and i certainly don't know who else is
working as a composer in british
television right now so i don't know who
the options are and
i don't have that much of an opinion
i'm scared that the story will end up
feeling rushed however i also have a
hunch that flex's plot will be concluded
in the three specials next year if that
ends up happening that's going to annoy
the hell out of me
now granted if that does happen that may
not
necessarily be chipnel's fault that
might be a programming issue that he
doesn't have control over
but that is gonna annoy me i won't blame
him in specific if that ends up
happening although i will still blame
him if this if these six episodes
give us nothing
firm and like if the entire point of the
plot is left to the later specials i
will criticize that in and of itself but
if the story he wanted to tell if he has
to find a way to stretch it over more
time that may not necessarily be his
fault
the doggy alien put me a bit in mind of
the 1996 cartoon road rovers a show i
only remember the title of this year
i
don't think i know that one
i heard that uh we germans get the web
of fear soon in german looking forward
to it i'll enjoy it
favors favorite tardis interior matt
smith's first one
uh do you think the visual style
aesthetic of the show will change in the
next era
um i don't know i think that's probably
gonna have more to do with who gets
brought on as um
as directors
so it's
it's hard to say
like it was a pretty
clear
um
visual shift for
jody whitaker's era now that's not to
say that things had never shifted i mean
you can look at series 1 and series 10
and definitely see a difference but that
was more of a gradual drift rather than
feeling like a deliberate choice to
shake up the aesthetic and the
visual approach
so i don't know maybe
maybe not
uh hi ben
yeah i see what you did there
are you surprised that yaz is no longer
a police officer
uh no because they never did anything
with that plot point anyways
the only time it seemed to have any
meaning whatsoever was in can you hear
me
where they kind of gave an origin story
for why she became one and that moment
worked well but other than that one bit
the fact that she was a cop
really did very little to inform her
character and didn't really
feed in or factor into much of anything
so
i had honestly kind of forgotten that
she was
do you think the series will work better
if we got
uh marathon instead of waiting weekly
releases i like the weekly release but
it doesn't work for this series
um
i don't know what i won't know until
it's done but
the question is kind of um
it's kind of backwards because
this was going to be released weekly it
was always going to be released weekly
and
uh
chidnal knew that
so
and then knowing that
to whatever extent they do but that
ratings still matter building something
for a format that isn't the format
you're actually releasing it in is just
really dumb
so
if at the other end of this if i if if
once this is done if i look at doctor
who flux and think you know what watched
altogether is a continuous thing it's
not that bad that will still be a
condemnation of how it was done
originally because that would mean he
wrote something for a format that wasn't
the format the thing was going to be
initially released in
that's just
stupid
oh it's like it's it's like the
criticism in it that's gone around in
comic books for a long time
the idea that a lot of comics are
written for the trade so individual
issues of comics have almost nothing
happened because they're being written
with the mindset that it's going to be
later collected in a trade paperback and
it's going to be five issues and so that
you basically have
what used to be one comic's worth of
events happening over five issues to be
sold as a trade later and comics suffer
for that
they're not better for being done that
way if you're going to write it for the
trade then just release it as a graphic
novel
write for the format you have
you can choose which doctor
to return for the anniversary
who would you choose between mcgahn or
eccleston those are my choices i would
i would put mcgahn slightly above
eccleston because i want him to get more
than seven good minutes
actually physically embodying the role
uh
for me murray gold's music defines
scenes uh
way too much john comber
john carpenter always said that music
should be like wallpaper it fits with
the scene and helps it but doesn't
define it
and honestly that's a fair criticism
like murray gold
could get overly bombastic and there
were definitely times that his music
would overtake the scene like honestly
that was at worst during smith sarah
because
there were so many variations of i am
the doctor and i am the doctor's a
really good piece of music but it just
was overused in places where it did not
belong and it would turn very innocuous
scenes in into this weird bombastic
moment you're like why isn't that
playing
ah
do you believe chimneal chose to leave
on his own a corridor do you think
someone at the bbc may had not fired him
but suggested he stepped down don't know
don't care
i i'm not here to guess about
internal politics if news ever comes out
that that did happen from a credible
source i'll have an opinion on that but
right now speculation i have no opinion
i have a hunch that jody's doctor will
be responsible for
none of the previous
doctors from hartnell on remembering
being the timeless child
okay so you think she's going to somehow
retroactively erase the memory of her
own previous selves
that's very um
amnesia the dark descent of you
did you hear about ruby rose's
accusations concerning some of the staff
and actors on the batwoman cast i did
uh warner brothers does not need that
okay go to this is the third time you're
asking mike tardis interior i answered
that earlier
please stop asking a question i've
already answered um yeah i did hear
about that warner brothers especially
after everything that came out with joss
whedon on
the
justice league set they really don't
need this now to be fair the television
division and the film division are not
actually run by the same people but it
is still owned by the same overall
company so it's a bad look right now
i kind of feel something similar about
how we watch classic who the series
don't work as well all in one in a dvd
like that's honestly true
but
i don't have the patience to only watch
like one a night but like sometimes it
hurts it more than others so like to
pick a key example
watchman
honestly both the new hbo show and the
uh the original work by alan moore
this needs to be digested in pieces with
time in between
and specifically if you are re used you
can buy watchmen as a trade it's one of
the best selling comic book trade
collections of all time
but
i will always tell people only read an
issue a night
do not binge through this because you
need to read it
sit with it soak it in think about it
and then come back because it was
written
knowing that there was going to be a
month between every issue and i don't
tell people they need to wait a month
between every issue but it was written
with the it was written with a density
that was justified because people were
going to be spending a lot of time
thinking about what they just read
before they read the next part
and to try and burn your way through it
does it a disservice now is that the
case with classic doctor who are like
it's too dense to be bench no but that's
just illustrative of the point overall
high voltage thank you once again for
the super chat much appreciated let's
not forget dudley simpson uh in the talk
of composers he definitely made bad
music but i think he gets enough love in
my opinion
huh
i don't know who that is
i feel like i should
but i don't
imdb
help me out
dudley simpson oh okay so uh doing the
music for the show up through the 80s
um yeah
yeah i mean like the the classic era
doctor who
uh music doesn't jump out at me too much
but
it it definitely works especially for
the time that it was being done
do you think chris will do some fans
something fanservicey for the century
special and do you think this could
affect the jody regen episode negatively
or positively i have no idea what he's
going to do and i i'm not really a good
person to ask
speculation
questions about
my brain rarely goes that way
gotta say i like the weeding cut
nonetheless and think mass snider cut is
not better
snyder cut is a more coherent film
i do have a soft spot for the whedon cut
because
i was just happy to see those characters
smiling
once in a while again but it's not a
good not it's not a good movie like as a
as a completed piece the snyder cut is a
is a better film
i'm not sure i like it more but it is a
better film
uh i just read the premise of the next
episode and i'm fearful that it'll be
another overstuffed episode okay don't
tell me i don't want to know
um
do you think flux will double down or
retcon the timeless child twist kind of
like what happened with rise of
skywalker
i don't know even odds at this point
because
the
the
popular you can call it a theory you can
call it request for a retcon was that
the master was lying
which
some people get really adamant about
which is yes possible but if he is lying
then that's again bad writing because
then you've delivered deliberately
delivered a twist
knowing that it was not
real
and that is not how you do twist
narrative
doing a twist and then untwisting it
just puts you right back where you
started what was the freaking point
especially with how little this
revelation has appeared to impact the
doctor as a person
so
i don't know
i would kind of rather he doesn't
just because i really want to know what
the hell story he he thought it was
necessary to do that in order to tell
and if it either turns out to be nothing
or he retcons it and doesn't do it
whatever he had thought previously then
it makes the entire thing
an absolutely pointless exercise and i
want to know what the point was supposed
to be
i want to know that there was a point i
that won't make me like it i've said
many many many many times justifying the
reason something is a certain way does
not mean that i like it but i would like
to know there was a point
because otherwise
how does anyone involved have a job can
i have their job
because i think i could do that better
if there was truly no point
please let there be a point i don't even
care if it's a bad point let there be a
point
to it
oh uh strum dynasty gaming once again
thank you very much for the super chat
favorite brigadier story ooh
um trying to think of the ones i've seen
i'm
i think
i'm leaning
doctor who in the silurians
he's good in everything though but i i
liked back when the there was more
direct tension between him and the
doctor and that was done really well
there
favorite dalek story uh probably just
dalek
uh thoughts on the weeping angels
returning until i know why it's there i
don't really have one
like that's the thing and that's another
thing i think people misconstrued about
my negativity towards the halloween
apocalypse um
i don't know whether any of the
individual component parts of this thing
are bad i won't know until i understand
why they're there but it was the
delivery method was the way they were
all piled together again lacking a clean
central pillar for everything to be
built around that made it not work for
me what do i think about the weaving
angels returning i don't know
depends on why if it ends up if the
answer ends up being fan service then
wasted that'll be my opinion but if it's
anything other than that
listen to the city of death sweet some
of dudley simpson's best work oh duly
noted
you seem really fed up with the current
doctor who can't be bothered vibes i
don't mean to be that negative i really
don't but the thing is at this point
as much as i want
very very
very much to be wrong
chibnall has not
done anything to
make me have faith in
him and the remainder of his tenure
he just hasn't
and i can only go on blind optimism for
so long when i've got now multiple
series that i have massive freaking
problems with
i i don't know how else to be at this
point i don't think it's so bad that i'm
going to
like suddenly turn on the show i like to
think i'm still being semi-constructive
and again i'm still finding bits i like
i l i can never remember his name i've
looked at it like 50 times but the dog
alien i like a lot
i like dan
i uh vinder or whatever his name was he
seemed like a neat guy i kind of liked
his vibe and his dynamic there are bits
here that i can still identify
good stuff
but it's been swimming in so much bad
lately
that i just
i don't i don't like being a downer
there it's happened repeatedly
um on the break room of geeks where i've
stopped reviewing
or talking about certain things because
i felt like all i was doing was crapping
on it
and i don't like doing that and i don't
think i'm quite there with doctor who
yet and even
even if i am i need to at least get
through the remainder of this so that we
can get to the point where things are
are gonna um do whatever they do in the
next phase of the show but
it
i'm just
tired both by the show
itself and i'm really exhausted uh by
the fandom
the fandom is [ __ ] draining
hey
are you worried rd rtd's first episode
is the 60th lot of pressure on his
shoulders no worried that i am uh about
the idea of him coming back at all
uh
all right i was trying to keep up with
the chat but i i i
need to
i need to give up on that all right new
type jb lee thank you very much for the
super chat even though ds9 is still a
good show i think the idea of exploring
the dark side of the federation is
overdone at this point it has kind of
like an over uh the over idealization of
the federation during the
um
uh during the original and the next
generation like that was a legitimate
criticism and there was plenty of stuff
to be mined by examining the other sides
of it but yeah that seems to become the
default but again that's because we
we have been going through phases of
dark and gritty and now we deconstruct
everything and
just tell me a good story
that's all i want i don't need my heroes
torn down just tell me a good story
that'd be that that be
really nice
ah
ignore the fandom that's what i do i do
it to the best of my ability thomas i do
not actively wander
into fan spaces but like
i run a channel where i talk about
doctor who a lot
i the the
i have to interact with the fandom
to some degree i can't
i can't completely you know like i say i
don't wander into doctors spaces i don't
go on reddit i don't go into dedicated
fan forums i'm i have a very light touch
on twitter like i hope i keep it at
arm's length as much as i possibly can
again not that i'm saying that all fans
are bad but it's just exhausting
yeah i'm used to certain parts of the
fandom because of star trek uh
yeah
why does the fandom for everything i
love suck
right now
star trek fandom sucks star wars fandom
sucks doctor who fandom sucks and that's
completely separate from whether or not
the movie shows etc of any of those
things are any good
ah
can you forgive the first episode of the
flux because it's set up episode and
it's mostly show don't tell like a
single piece of a larger picture
no
i don't mean to yell at you jamie
but i
that is not an excuse
it can't be
because
as i noted before
we are getting these one episode per
week that is the format you have to
build your story in a way that works
digesting it one episode per week and
giving us no satisfying even bookend
moment for the parts that you've been
dealing with giving us no central pillar
around everything seems to be based and
just piling on a ton of stuff oh that
we'll deal with later is bad
storytelling it's not even good
serialized storytelling you can do
serialized storytelling where you lay in
a bunch of stuff at the beginning that
doesn't make sense but will later but
it's better than this it has to be this
is still
bad even by that measure so no i will
not and will never excuse this or
anything that gives me a bad weak start
on the hope of oh it'll be better when
all pieces are in play it has to work
now because you are giving me
a
single episode even in part of a
serialized story you are giving me a
piece of a story that has to give me
something
it cannot be nothing but teases because
that is serving me a meal that is
nothing but
garnish so no
i reject that and i don't mean to be
yelling at you i am not mad at you as a
person i have just been seeing this all
over my comments and it's come up
repeatedly in the chat and
no
okay
i'm all right
can always rely on the red dwarf fandom
boys from the dwarf
i think at this point the best fandoms
are the most casual fandoms anything
where a fandom can be hardcore dedicated
has a tendency to go south i don't know
anyone who's like a hardcore red dwarf
fan it's not something that you can be
hardcore about it's a relaxed show it
has a relaxed fan base
uh
all right
uh
here's a great comparison first episode
of it's a sin introduces three story
lines that don't initially intersect but
the story is still well placed since
thematically cohesive yes
because all three of those characters
while they have not met each other and
uh we don't know how they connect yet
they are all telling stories that are
thematically
the same thing so we already understand
even if we don't know the logistics of
how they tied together we understand
from episode one why they are being told
in the same space that's a very good
example
sorry i didn't mean to make you upset i
love your stuff but i appreciate your
commentary it's okay and like again
jamie like i'm not
i'm not mad at you
i've just i've gotten so annoyed with
that um
with that
suggestion
that
i'm supposed to basically withhold an
opinion
of any kind
because we don't know everything that's
going on yet like no i you gave me a
piece
i am allowed to have an opinion on that
piece my opinion may change once all
pieces are in play but i still get to
have an opinion on that piece
um
bobby k thank you so much for the super
chat much appreciated love your channel
long longtime viewer i thought i'd give
a little tip my question for you is
what's your favorite version of doctor
who theme song series four
um and it was also the same one used for
the specials i believed they they pumped
up the violins just a little bit and and
like the percussion on the front end so
that
it just hits a little bit harder before
the
comes in and it mwah
it's
gold
i think the only casual fandom i'm part
of is the jaws fandom and the back of
the future fandom yep yep those are
those are nice laid-back casual fandoms
good call
uh
to quote yahtzee crochet the one flaw of
portal is it has the worst fans in the
world i believe the exact quote uh from
the yahtzee crow show was you'll be
pleased to know i did eventually find a
flaw it's got the worst [ __ ] fans in
the world i i
i have a tendency to put the uh
the compilations of zero punctuation on
his background noise so i
i can quote a disturbing amount of uh of
zero punctuation and yahtzee's work
new type jb lee
thank you again so very much for the
super chat if you're tired of doctor who
i recommend other british uh sci-fi
classics like blake seven by terry
nation like i know a lot of doctor who
fans like um bike seven and i do wanna
give it a shot at some point
but it's worth pointing out the only
reason i'm able to get into classic who
was because i got into modern who um i
retro sci-fi is something that i can
appreciate but rarely enjoy very much
um in the end
i i needed my appreciation of the modern
era before i could even try getting into
classic and even then it took a little
while for me to properly tune into the
wavelength to where i am now where i
feel like i appreciate it decently
do you think swarm has potential to be
the definitive villain of jody's era
above the likes of ashad or
uh simsha
i mean it should have been a shot ashad
was a brilliant concept and brilliant in
his first appearance and then
very little was done and he was killed
um so
whether or not
the swarm
will be i mean
if it happens it'll be by default
um i think more likely the master this
version of the master sasha wants master
will be
uh the tmnt fandom's pretty chill too
well they have to be because that thing
gets rebooted so often if they were as
um
rabid
about every little change the
the fandom couldn't exist anymore so
they have to be pretty flexible good
call i like that do i like mtv uh which
decade because mtv is a completely
different beast decade to decade um
although consistently overall the answer
is no for the most part no
are you still watching legends of
tomorrow yes liz and i just barely
started watching the latest season
because it hit netflix we are going to
be doing it a little bit at a time as we
are able to because it's something that
we watch together so it'll be a while
before i'm caught up on it
i don't think that the master was lying
i think that the matrix was lying and
someone put that in there in order to
make the master so angry that he killed
all the time lords
i don't like that wrong for two reasons
because from a grand meta narrative
perspective the doctor lying or the
matrix lying is still the exact same
problem you're still introducing a twist
that um ultimately is you're going to
undo so what was the freaking point
because we're right back where we
started and second of all that's the
kind of
twisting of like oh we'll do this and
get this result that i
hate
because
it basically requires a perfect
psychoanalysis of the master and given
how much the master changes from
regenerations
i find it very contrived that someone
could be certain that the master would
kill
all of the time lords based off this
information
because i don't think every incarnation
of the master would have done that and
it makes the whole thing just shakier as
a as a premise
dennis varti
thank you very much for the super chat
thank you for your reviews thank you for
the support i appreciate it greatly
um do i watch b stars no i've had it on
my to watch list but like everything
else it'll probably just sink lower and
lower lower on that list over time
because there's never enough time in the
world
now i would have said that the flash
fans are laid back folks and then i
heard that people don't like iris and i
was like eh see i gave up on flash um
after two seasons when i heard that the
third season was another evil speedster
i'm like i can't with this anymore and i
was too tired of being annoyed at barry
because
god damn it barry
it's like a mantra watching that show
what three words were you would you use
to describe the 13th doctor's
personality and character
secretive optimistic explorer
high voltage thank you again i really do
appreciate that i think i asked this
long time ago
um but do you think you'll ever cover
steven universe like you did gravity
falls would love to hear your opinion
maybe uh steven universe is something
that i'm gonna i'm gonna try and see if
my kid uh is up for getting into because
we like we watch shows together but
unfortunately right now the shows that
we watch together are um
either between seasons or new seasons
haven't hit disney plus yet because like
we watch the owl house together we're
waiting on new episodes we watch
amphibia season three only just started
airing who knows when we'll hit disney
plus
um you know we did she-ra we did hilda
don't know if that's even getting a
third season so
i i'm gonna have her try steven universe
and if she digs it then yes i'll
probably catch up on it and have
thoughts um
[Music]
you know in the not so distant future if
she doesn't i don't know when i'll find
time to watch it on my own it's one of
the things that like kind of makes life
easier is it if there's something that
we both
like together she'll make sure that i
make the time to watch it left on my own
devices i'm not nearly as good about
that
you wanted joe martin as 14. now that's
uh probably not happening with rtd
what's your wish and or your hunch for
the next doctor i have no hunch i have
no wish
i i i will direct you to my old video
about uh actors who i think would make
good doctors but i don't have a
definitive pick oh it should be this
person
i just don't
where's the owl house reviews we have
been waiting two months where is it i'm
waiting for the rest of season two
because i don't have that much of an
opinion on the additional five episodes
beyond the five i already reviewed
so when the rest of season 2 hits you
will get another review video
well when the rest of season 2 hits
disney plus who the hell knows how long
that's going to take
i'll describe b-stars for you it's
zootopia except x-rated yeah no i
already knew that did you ever check out
samurai jack i did i wish i liked the
fifth season better
uh
it's not
terrible but
if there was ever a show that did not
need
a love interest character
at all it's samurai god damn jack
and yet
and yet
paul thank you very much
for the super chat who's your favorite
new who master incarnation missy
easy call not even close
uh the 13th doctor is an actually
timeless child they just pass through an
unreality pocket the same thing that
caused crichton to think lister was an
android
how funny would it be if they
and i'm not saying this sincerely but
how funny would it be if the if we got
into
um rtd's first new series
and um
explain the whole thing the way the
third series of red dwarf did in a text
crawl that moves too fast to read and
then just moves forward with how it
wants to do things
oh discord thank you carowind um
apologies if you were telling me that
earlier um but
uh
yes i will take a look at that
so this this is your reminder that the
other way to guarantee that your
questions get answered is to be on the
council of geeks discord which is
a patreon exclusive perk so
um if you don't want to have to chuck
money at me for every question to
guarantee alaska that's an option too
let's see
oh
we just got one comment this time i'm
dodging the stream because i don't want
want spoilers and that
is fair
easy peasy and we're back
um have you watched doom patrol no i
keep meaning to
that one ah god see like it's
between um all the stuff i do between
streams and podcast records and twitch
and
now doctor who reviews and trying to get
weekly videos done and
i'm still trying to deal with the last
few uh remaining to-do list items off my
last kickstarter
um
it's really hard for me to justify
watching a show that i have not been
commissioned for
and
uh isn't something i think i'm gonna get
a video out of i mean that said like
once i watch a season of doom patrol
i'll do a video on it but it would be a
break room video and get a lot of
views and i know that and that's a that
is a frustrating reason to not watch
something or to put off watching
something but that's kind of the reality
of my life doing this professionally
um
[Music]
anyways
let's see oh did i actually catch up
with the chat whoo
what do you think of catherine tate on
the office where i first saw her i have
not seen the uk office
episodes or was she in the american i
only saw one season of the american
office it was fine i didn't stick around
i did not watch any of the uk office
because even before it became
fashionable to do so i never
liked ricky gervais
i've never liked him
uh what do you think of sasha 1 as the
master in general i think he's got great
energy he's definitely doing um a
version of a
manic energy doctor that i like a lot
better than when sim did it
so
it feels like a refinement of that one
genuine question do you have more fun
ripping into things you don't like or
talking about things you do like i have
more fun
usually
talking about things i like
it depends on the reason i don't like it
i don't enjoy
ripping into things that i don't like
but it's tied to something that i have a
commitment to like i don't particularly
enjoy ripping into episodes of doctor
who because i love doctor who i don't
particularly enjoy ripping into
something star wars related that i
didn't like because i love star wars i
don't have any problem at all
ripping into um things that are just bad
on their face um that i don't have a big
commitment into so you know every now
and then so like
[ __ ] that i've seen like so like when i
did what did i what the hell did i just
watch videos on things like starchaser
or
um last christmas
that was fun because it didn't it didn't
hurt me to hate it
uh the hate was oddly energizing
but when it's something that i love
ripping into it
doesn't feel good it can feel cathartic
it can feel necessary sometimes but it
doesn't feel good
so
if
if i had the choice i would
i would talk much more about things i
like than things i don't
that having been said
algorithmically
negative stuff trends better than
positive
i have hard data on that
depressing reality of this job
uh
oh bobby k
thank you very much for the super chat
i'll have to look at supporting the
patreon um but i do enjoy the hard hands
we get from tipping do you have plans to
review midnight mass ah at present no
because i don't know hey i don't know
when i'm gonna get to it and be
uh i'm a little iffy about um
talking netflix stuff right now like i'm
not so harsh that i'm gonna be like i
will not engage with this the way i am
with say harry potter stuff right now
but
you know knowing that netflix fired the
transgender employee who organized the
walkout i'm
not thrilled with them
right now so
like for instance i'm i'm gonna try
actually tonight later tonight try and
finish watching um
the last of the fear street movies i
don't know if i'll actually make a video
on it because i don't
really
wanna promote
netflix's stuff right now i'm not gonna
say never because i'm kind of at never
with harry potter but like right now
it's just feels kind of gross
as a trans person you know
and again that's not me getting rid of
netflix but just not loving the idea of
bigging up their stuff and yes i know i
did the squid game review
um that was very um
praising of it but even that is
that's kind of brought to like because
the creator of that got a slim freaking
paycheck that involved no residuals so
netflix made a ton of money on that and
uh
the creator of that show did not how
dark do you think doctor who should go
like in terms of themes tone and
atmosphere as darkseid wants on a one-o
on a one-off basis
individual episodes can be as dark as
they want midnight is dark as hell and
it's great
honestly heaven sense pretty damn dark
but
this that should never be the tone of
the show overall
i love that the show can go that dark i
never want it to be the default
do you think the doctor should ever
revisit susan at this point it's been so
much time
um that i'm inclined to say it's best to
just leave it be
that i i don't it would feel weirdly
final
it's like broadly speaking it's the kind
of thing i think you do
as an ending almost
have
if you were planning to truly end the
show forever you don't kill the doctor
permanently
you have whatever the incarnation is go
back
to see and just be with
and around
susan
to just bring it full circle from that
speech of one day i shall come back
and have that be the end but since i
don't want doctor who to ever end
i don't want that to happen
um
i think you'd like steven universe
because it seems like a monster of the
week show but has great lore mysteries
and it covers toxic
toxics
top picks like ptsd toxic relationships
etc i've heard very good things about it
um but yeah i haven't gotten to it yet
uh could tom cavanaugh be a good doctor
maybe
not an idea that excites me
um
i do need to wrap it up soon
uh ben douglas
thank you so much you get a heart
favorite jody era episode can you hear
me
i love the thematics and the way that
they're woven into the story and i think
as a piece in and of itself it stands up
very well
at least it does with my read on it i
know a lot of people don't like it um
and it's not actually a full-throated
defense to say you know you don't
understand it because the way that i
understand that episode i love it but
if the episode does not properly
communicate
what it is meant how it is meant to be
read that is a fault and i'm not somehow
smarter because i got it
like if the if a significant portion of
the audience doesn't get what you're
doing then you did something wrong but
as someone who feels like i do get what
that episode is doing i like it a lot
what do you think of the we being anvils
being used much like the weevils and
torchwood that's a terrible idea like
the like the default they're just around
no good grief
um
have you ever watched the x-files not
bits and pieces i never got into it
and i've heard way too many mixed things
about how it ultimately panned out
uh let's see
uh annabelle shirley the actress who
plays claire the weeping angel lady
played lauren in being human series one
i barely remember being human
i did watch the first series
i barely remember that at all
uh talking about doctor dark doc
dark
doc
tore
who
episodes are there any that you believe
were too dark
uh episodes as a whole
no
i think um
things like the
don't cremate me from dark water was
possibly too dark a
a beat to dark a concept specifically
given the intended audience of the show
like that is the kind of idea that is
gonna traumatize kids
um
but episode as a whole no i don't think
so
neither ms wicked wolf they both suck
neither of those are good
songs all right i am going to wrap it up
all right
i barely remember being human is a weird
thing to say
oh god somebody's got to clip that one
out of context
[Music]
okay we're done thank you all for
joining me
for this one um i'll be back in two
weeks and probably talking more doctor
who again because by then we'll have
three episodes of flux to uh to be
talking about
but um
thank you all for joining me
uh i hope that you be safe
be well and be kind and please remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
michelle